hello everyone and welcome to the second
game of the World Chess Championship
match between the animation and the
dinglier and we've seen what happened in
game one nipple has surprised the dinga
very early on but the ding defended well
and in the end it just um unwind in a in
a very nice drive it was an enjoyable
game nonetheless many hidden variations
I like made a 43 minute video about it
which is okay quite long so I'm gonna
try not to make this one as long but I
will answer one question before we check
out the game and that is you guys asked
who were the players uh seconds that was
the the question that was asked most in
the comment section
is uh hunger is number one player and
that is the rihad Rapport
a very unique style very very
interesting player very aggressive
player you never know what to expect
from him and he's definitely someone you
want at your side when coming at a
player like
ianashienda uh did the influence of his
play will definitely be felt in this
game like for those of you who haven't
seen this game I mean you you really are
in for a treat and nepo's uh second I I
don't think there's been a lot of
discussion about him is of course a very
strong Russian Grandmaster Nikita
vitugov and if I if I get any more
insight on on what they've been working
on I will I shared during the match uh
and here there's also a very nice photo
of Ding and Rehab the uh going into the
playing Hall I imagine uh when ding was
asked after the game yesterday about his
second that this is what the thing said
I like his creative playing style I also
I can speak English with him and he can
help me come across better and improve
my speaking we also have many things in
common uh we like music of the 80s so
you know do with that what you will but
you know probably while they are
preparing they are listening to some 80s
music and becoming very good friends so
that being said let's check out the game
and also okay the first move was made by
none other than the uh then Timur tool
of the president of the Kazakhstan just
Federation and CEO of Freedom holding
Corp General partner of the video world
championship match so there you have it
uh very very serious
move being made staring into the camera
like that waiting for his photo the to
appear perfect ding busy staring at nepo
doing the death stare and I think nepo
is just goofing around being his usual
self so that being said let's check out
the second game uh truly a beauty uh
ding opens with Pawn to D4 we have
Knight to F6 by nepo C4 with E6 Knight
to F3 and D5 so a standard Queen's
Gambit declined where ding already uh
plays a move that has sort of never been
played before it's been played in a few
online games and it has been played once
over the board 20 years ago in a very
low level game uh in between players of
1500 rating and that is spawn the H3 now
this is a move you don't want to see in
a World Chess Championship match and
it's something when nipple saw it he
just made his um classic nipple face
like
and uh I don't know uh definitely it
feels unpleasant you know that of course
your opponent will surprise you from
time to time in a wheelchair
championship match you just don't expect
it in a Queen's Gambit declined on move
four like that that just doesn't happen
but it is what um I think uh managed to
do and it's definitely at the influence
of rehab Rapport being felt here and
like I said there is that one game where
C5 was played but here deep captors and
C4 is what nipple plays and I don't know
we can consider any of these positions a
completely new game but I I really want
to make it the the H3 move because uh
the the other games weren't really
notable ones so here E3
a lot of people were also discussing
something like geek foreign Bishop to G2
but I would just be going
um crazy so I think just wants to play a
solid game with the inclusion of H3 and
that every position uh after every move
they make Nepal will have to recollect
all of the positions that he knows uh by
heart and then he will have to figure
out how does H3 influence all of those
positions so it's really a mind-bending
idea uh we have Pawn to C5 now comes
Bishop characters on C4 and pawn to A6
preparing B5 so again all very standard
Queens Gambit declined ideas with
castles and now Knight the C6 and Knight
the C6 is a very nice move uh also if
you want you could play C captures on D4
let's say Knight captures and Bishop to
C5 and now let's say B3 and Bishop
captures and D4 kind of force white to
play with an isolated d-pawn uh but uh
White really doesn't mind it's an ic6
Bishop to B2 let's say B5 attacks the
bishop there's even D5
and you could definitely try something
like this Knight the B4 Bishop act T2
you sacrifice a pawn Knight beat
captures on D5 and now A4 going after
the B5 pawn and if B for Queen to D4 so
even positions like these are possible
where you give up a pawn uh for some
very active play you have the bishop
pair you have the very nice Queen Bishop
combo here
um uh definitely something to consider
uh but uh that's probably why he went
Knight to the C6 he doesn't want to even
give ding the possibility of going for
some sort of an attack information like
that and uh Knight the C3 and okay the
position is as it is but the situation
on the clock is very different uh an
hour and 53 minutes for Ding and an hour
and 36 minutes for uh yeah
to waste a lot of time uh working out
how does uh H3 influence all of these
positions we have Punta B5 now Bishop to
D3 and Bishop to B7 of course dingos for
Ponte A4 and now Yan needs to decide how
to continue this game does he want to
play C capture on D4 doesn't want to
play C4 does he want to just ignore this
and play Bishop to E7 so all of these
ideas are nice the problem is let's say
play Pawn to C4 then you always get a
captures on V5 and after he captures
Rook captures an A8 let's say Bishop
captures uh you're gonna move the bishop
back and okay you can play this you have
the B and C Pawn at some point B4 can be
played uh it's uh maybe even prepared
with Queen to B8 it's a very nice
position on the other hand if you don't
play that if you play C captures on D4
you will get a similar response a
character State captures and Rook
captures Bishop captures and not Knight
captures on D4 Knight captures e
captures and you will lose the B5 Pawn
uh at some point let's say Bishop the C6
even prepare it with Queen to E2 Queen
to D7 and now you just trade everything
by Shop characters Bishop captures Queen
captures Queen captures Knight captures
and we end this line with the white
being up a full Pawn uh probably it will
end in a draw but you know it is black
will have to defend for the rest of the
game other option is just ignored with
Bishop to E7 but Ian takes on the
challenge and plays Pawn to B4 and okay
here we have Knights the E4 and now
Knight the A5 and this is a beautiful
move uh Bayan uh he's down half an hour
on the clock I think has someone hour
and 50 minutes the Nepal has an hour and
20 minutes and here yeah he plays this
Knight the A5 move which we are going to
discuss uh I will just show you what is
objectively sort of uh the the move that
should be played here and that is Queen
to D5 the problem here is that after
Knight captures in G captures Pawn to E4
you will bring your queen back to D7 now
D5 and now after captures captures and
queen captures there's a rookie one
check Bishop to E7 and now even Bishop
to F4 uh with always having the option
of going Bishop T for the
uh to minimize Black's pressure along
this diagonal but still it's not a not a
great position for uh it's it's either a
great position for both players or not a
great position for a Hydra player let's
say Bishop to C2 okay yeah you can trade
Queens here let's say queen captures
Rook captures and the game continues a
very very unbalanced uh stuff here so
while this is possible uh nipple goes
for Knight to A5 and he offers a full
Pawn here and it's not a new new move it
has been played before by none other
than Levon arunian but not quite in this
position it's been played twice uh
gookish headed against Levon and also uh
ding had it against Lavon and Dean
actually defeated Levon
um in this game the the problem is uh uh
here uh H3 wasn't played instead of H3
Rook the E1 was played and now even if
nipple knows this that this position has
been reached but it's very hard because
Dean had it against LaVon in the 2021
speed Chess Championship so it would be
weird if Nepal knew that by heart uh but
still even if he knew that he would have
to
uh figure out how the inclusion of H3
and not having the Rook honey one
changes the position uh but okay here uh
it means that he sacrifices the C5 pawn
and it would uh be very very uh
interesting if ding captures this ding
does not capture it he actually plays
Knight captures and F6 with check and
it's sort of probably if um the ding
discussed this Knight captures on F6
does seem like uh rehab the report move
rather than a ding move uh because ding
would probably just capture on C5 and
you would get something like this B
capture some d-captors it's similar to
what ding actually played against Levon
Knight to D7 and now Pawn to C6
the the same move that Ding player
against Lavon only would have to the
inclusion of H3 Bishop captures now you
have that capture with the Knight order
with the bishop but whatever you do sort
of discordinates her pieces Bishop
captures and now Knight to D4 puts
pressure on the bishop here and if
Knight the C5 now you you can play Bush
of the C2 getting the bishop out of
Harm's Way if Bishop to E4 you will of
course trade captures captures and now
Bishop to D2 just getting ready to
double up on the C file the black will
trade captures captures and you have
this position where if black wants black
can just play Knights the C6 and trade
everything off let's say Rook after D1
Knight captures Queen captures let's say
queen captures and The Rook captures and
now the question is uh White is of
course a much more active let's say the
B4 Pawn gets defended what comes to C1
and is black in time to get the Rook
Center game or is the white just too
active for example castles Rook to D7
and now you can just play Rook after d8
and it seems that black is in time to
uh prevent any serious material loss so
that's kind of what you would get if you
go for this Knight captures
um on C5 uh sorry about that if you go
for that Knight captures on C5 idea
uh sorry uh accidentally uh rewind a bit
too much uh so yeah not Knight captures
on C5 Knight captures and F6 is what
being placed and this is sort of the uh
the the idea of a rapport or at least
what everyone is thinking and now G
captures an F6 not Queen captures on F6
if you play Queen captures on F6 then
Pawn to E4 uh and now uh black isn't
really enjoying his time here uh Bishop
to G5 is coming next so you have to play
Pawn to H6 and now if Bishop to D2 uh
meaning that if C captures on D4 the B4
Pawn will become weak at some point uh C
capture Sandy for now even Rook to C1
and now uh how do you deal with this
it's it's very hard to play this with
black E5 has to be played if you don't
play this play something like Bishop to
D6 then white plays E5 and all of a
sudden black is in big trouble let's say
E5 Bishop captures Knight captures Queen
captures and not just Bishop capture
some B4 the black king uh will will not
be castling and that's gonna be a huge
problem so that's why nepo uh plays G
captures on F6 a queen captures is not a
mistake it's just uh uh you know you're
basically inviting E4 so G captures on
F6 and the ding still plays Pawn to E4
and this is uh basically throwing down
the gauntlet this is not challenging
nipple to a duel as it uh really uh asks
the question what happens after Pawn to
C4 and therefore did not take a long
time he just played one to C4 and now
Bishop back to C2 you could also
consider Bishop to B1 but then you just
allow this Knight to B3 move and uh it's
maybe a bit too much to give to Black so
Bishop the C2 and now we have Queen to
C7 and this is a very flexible idea by
Nepal point is that B3 of course
everyone wants to play B3 you guys are
looking gonna be three let's play this
but after Bishop to B1 and let's say
Bishop to B4 you can actually defend
this quite easily Bishop to D2 and now
even if Queen to B6 you're just gonna
play Bishop captures Queen captures and
it's not a problem Queen can come to E2
Queen can come to E1 you can offer Queen
trade Queen can come to C1
so it's not a problem at some point you
will develop the bishop to get the Rook
into the game and your position will be
fine however after Queen the C7 it's not
as simple because now it's very hard for
ding to find the move uh the problem is
now if you just continue development
Bishop T3 to sort of get your Rook into
the game now Nepal will play B3 and
after Bishop to B1 now Bishop to B4 and
now it's much much different than what
we've discussed uh you've already played
Bishop to E3 so you're gonna have to
waste the tempo with uh Bishop to D2 and
now for example characters captures
there's already Queen side castles now
you're gonna play Rook G8 Rook G6 double
up here uh it's gonna be a much better
position for black so instead we have
Bishop to D2 by ding also uh notable
here is Queen to E1 uh just uh just uh
show you how How Deep The Rabbit Hole
really goes B3 Bishop to D1 and now if
you try uh and now of course the the B4
square is covered the bishop cannot help
out and if you try Knight to C 6 to sort
of get the bishop there just to Bishop
to D2 so it's not a problem and um it's
uh uh you know it's it's definitely
possible but Queen T1 would have gone a
long way uh instead ding played Bishop
to D2 and now nepo just plays Rook to G8
we have rooked the C1 so ding does get
his Bishop into the game but now Queen
side castles and the ding is no longer
up on time here they are both um around
the one hour mark so around 60 Minutes
for both and here yeah ding continued
with Bishop to D3 it looks like a really
good move because the well the Queen and
King are on the C file uh the way you
should have played this is either King
to H1 or queen to E1 now you're going
after the B4 pawn and nipple would
probably go for an active plan like Pawn
to F5 and now if Bishop captures and B4
you will get punished Bishop captures
Queen captures and not just F captures
an E4 and you are getting destroyed here
let's say Knight T1 Rook captures on D4
and the the entire position and just
opens up
you're not going to be able to hold this
so instead after a queen side castles
Bishop to D3 right away biting but now
just King to B8 and here that being
played Rook to E1 here it's all it is a
difficult position and it's very hard to
find the move here for ding like King to
H1 always begs to be played but he
played Rook to E1 and here and nepo just
gave him a big slap in the face so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this slapping idea uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh instant brilliancy and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Ponte F5 uh if you haven't seen the
game and you actually found this then
you are a true master of tactics the
problem is and this is what the ding
definitely missed uh is that if you uh
capture this ecap there's an F5 which
would otherwise be a great move uh there
is Rook captures on D4 and the White's
entire position just gets destroyed the
problem is if you accept the Rook black
plays a rook captures on G2 check and
after King to F1 it seems that white is
just much better there's Rook captures
on F2 you give up the other Rook as well
and now after King captures there's the
incredible Queen to H2 check and now
whatever you play you get to check maybe
you play King to F1 just Queen to G2 is
Checkmate if you go up the board queen
king to E3 then Bishop to H6 will be
Checkmate so very unfortunate for ding
but it is the new reality that he has to
get accustomed to uh so it's not uh not
easy to find the move here there's
basically no good move here to play it
ding in fact plays the the top move
recommended by the engine which is not
easy and the previous move Dean played
Bishop C2 to D3 and now you have to be
incredibly strong mentally to accept uh
or admit that that's a mistake and just
play the move back but back to C2 but
the thing did play at the end he spent a
lot of time here like uh half an hour
he's already down to 23 minutes uh which
is bad in itself but not only that his
position is really bad and here never
plays Knight the C6 a top move
recommended by the engine uh even though
uh F6 seems like a very human thing to
do just opening up the G file like that
for the black queen uh it's possible to
play it either way like uh Queenie Queen
E2 preparing Queen to F1 to defend if
one to E5 lights up onto D5 Queen G7
threatens Checkmate Queen to F1 now even
F4 uh I mean there's not much for for
black to do here you can put the this
bishop on C5 you can put this Bushman C
wait go after the H3 Pawn uh you will
get destroyed here but Knight the C6 uh
even more precise if you ask our good
friend the engine and now we have Bishop
to G5 biting
uh yeah I've checked with uh with cese
in the Norwegian supercomputer Bishop to
B1 is sort of the top move for white uh
but still it feels um uh in insufficient
because after uh Bishop to D1 you can
just play Knight captures on D4 uh not
Knight capture Sandy for that would be
making it easy for uh for white F
captures on e4 and now after Bishop
captures and um E4 Ponte F5 and now uh
if you don't want to lose the D4 Pawn
you will have that captran C6 Queen
captures and now okay you can uh sort of
maybe try and survive this let's say
King to F1 uh stopping any Queen
captures and F3 ideas but still it's
just a really bad position for white
however this was the uh best attempt for
ding he played Bishop to G5 and now it
if nepo plays anything other than the
move that really crushes thing uh ding
might actually have a way of saving the
game so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the second or top
move while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh always going
for that instant kill and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Rook captures and G5 that's the good
stuff and interestingly during the the
live coverage Anish giri mentioned at
this moment after never played a rook
captures on G4 that he had a nightmare
that he had to share a room with Hans
Neiman now I don't know why Rook
captures on G5 reminded him of this
nightmare uh I don't know if you have
any any ideas do share in the comments
but okay Knight captures on G5 and not
Knight captures on D4 so you are down
the exchange but you've completely
destroyed the White's position and uh
how do you defend you have to move the
queen away from the D file Queen to H5
was played by Ding and now comes Pawn to
F6 again you could consider some other
moves like Bishop to C5 uh and the the
thing is that if Queen captures on F7
there's even Knight to F3 check look at
this uh uh I mean this is disgusting
Knight captures or G cap doctors doesn't
really matter Queen to G3 with check
that's why Bishop to C5 is so strong and
after King to H1 Queen captures and G5
again you're just getting completely
destroyed here there's nothing you can
do uh so that's one way to do it uh
nipple decides to do it with F6 he
finally opens up the G file for the
queen uh Knight to F3 uh you could also
play Knight captures on H7 and the
nipple definitely had this cover let's
say queen to G7 and now if Knight
captures an f8 Rook captures Now The
Rook also comes to the G file so not a
lot to do here it's Bishop B1 you can
play Rook to G8 and G3 it's uh possible
but still F4 and you just um you just
resign here so instead a ding went back
Knights to F3 but not nipple just the
trades down Knight captures on C2 Rook
captures and Bishop captures on e4 and
this is a very classy move by nepo uh F
captures an E4 seems like the move you
want to play because it kind of chases
away the defender but after Knight D2 uh
what what do you play here there's no
easy way to continue the attack attack
if E3 just Rook captures and now if
Queen to C6 threatening Checkmate
there's Knight to F3 and it's not easy
continuing this even if Rook to D1 check
you can block with Rook D1 captures
captures and the Knight still covers the
G2 Square so always remember Knights are
tricky bastards so afterward captures on
C2 nipple just played Bishop captures on
C2 attacks The Rook here Rook to D2 and
now ding only has 14 minutes on the
clock but that's uh the you know the
least of his problems nipple plays
Bishop to D6 again the absolute top move
recommended by the engine uh now with
the terrible threat of Bishop captures
on F3 removing the defender of the H2
Square then comes the bishop to H2 check
and then he picks up the Rook on D2 so
that's the main idea and there's really
no way to to counter this in order to
stop this idea you will have to allow C3
and you know that one C3 lens there's no
surviving this so a ding Christ King to
H1 this prevents the idea that we've
discussed of Bishop to H to check after
Bishop captures an F3 but now of course
Pawn to C3 B captures B captures with
Rook to D4 and now Pawn to C2 and here
again uh C1 is coming so ding play Queen
to H6 regarding the C1 Square twice but
here nepo just played a pawn to E5 he
actually just came to the board and he
instantly played Pawn to E5 and he was
in this position and moved 29 that
dingler and resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the problem is The Rook is out of
squares you don't have this Square you
don't have this you don't have this you
don't have this and of course you don't
have D2 because you then block the
Queen's uh defense of the C1 Square so
you don't have a move here also you
don't have this and you don't have this
so you're just losing a rook or you have
to give it up for the bishop but then uh
you're not uh you were up the exchange
but now you're just down too much
material so a ding stops the suffering
here he stops the clock and he
congratulations on his first victory in
His World Chess Championship match
against the ding lyron which is
incredible this is uh as the second game
of the match but it is Yan's first game
with the black pieces he uh outplayed
the ding with the with the white he
surprised him he had some interesting
ideas that could lead maybe to
uh there's some winning chances but here
uh with with black he absolutely
obliterated ding ding ding surprised him
and he had a nice follow-up to the
surprise but then uh you know at some
point he he just completely fell apart
it just it it's almost like uh he
couldn't decide whether it was him
playing or a rapper playing uh here
after this uh uh night's day five move
was played because uh ding already
played this line and he knows that it's
a good line and he he played it well he
won a very nice game but here Knight
captures an F6 this really does look
like the the influence of real hard
rapper so they're gonna have to brush up
on it a little bit they have to decide I
don't know who who is actually playing
the match so uh uh I don't know it it
looks very it looks like he was trying
to play both his style and and Rapport
style and then in in the end he just
couldn't decide what to play especially
this bishop Bishop uh here after C4 and
then uh here this bishop to D3 movie he
he played this incredibly quickly
because for all the other moves he spent
a lot of time in the lounge and he just
came back like after an hour after half
an hour to make a move but this one he
played fairly quickly and it was just I
mean uh totally uh bad idea like it had
no business business being played here
takes the first game with black very
nicely done by him and what does this
mean for ding it means that now he will
no longer be able to play solid lines he
will no longer be able to accept the
draw in every game he will have to look
for a chance to bounce back pretty much
at every opportunity that he gets that
and what does that mean for us for us
that that means that as of game three of
the World Chess Championship Match we
will have a a much more interesting
match because uh the games will be more
open there there will be more more
chances more more pushing more
sacrificing more everything and I think
this uh is very good like the worst
thing that could happen is like you know
the first 10 games end in a draw and
then you know it's it's pretty stale but
now that we have a result I think we are
in for a treat for a big treat uh for
the uh for the entirety of the of the
World Chess Championship Match uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by Yan we'll
see what happens in game three uh I
would like to thank ravishing reptiles
YouTube Carlos
in the James Cashman for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World but for now we are
covering the World Chess Championship
match and remember tomorrow is a rest
day so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day